[Music]
hi everybody harry potter here for team
coco i'm in john hamm's dressing room
this gentleman is on the television show
mad men but right now he's here he's on
the patrol looking better than ever look
at you uh we're here
hey how's it going oh you okay yeah yeah
no good happened was that off-putting no
it's a lot there's love really yeah
there's a lot going on there too much i
just read in the trades uh
that uh christian bale this is his last
batman movie you and i we pitch
ourselves to warner brothers we're
hearing the lot as batman and rob
your thoughts
it's not the worst idea ever you
physically were right for it we are
right for it right i'm batman you're
robin
you didn't see it going that way
traditionally and i guess again you know
we can play against type as much as you
want but traditionally but
you know batman and robin are a little
taller you know once taller than the
other and i'm i'm significantly taller
and broader
uh and larger than you you have to know
what you just said circle you have to
know that it can't be it while you are
stating fact is still a little hurt you
have so many other things going on
uh
your advancing age gives you a lot more
experience wisdom think about wisdom i
like that you're spinning this
positively but again you're receiving a
hairline okay one face again negative a
negative thing that's negative it is
negative things so much that you have to
offer
uh i don't disagree with that rapier wit
and by that i mean yes what are you
sharp as a rapier not you tell more rape
jokes
i do not tell i'm not it's not rapey
nobody in the world knows what rapier we
explain you're showing off your big shot
language uh
it's
my language that's my youtube channel
you went between linguistic and language
exactly what happened you know why
because i thought linguistics would have
been wrong and i panicked no because you
that linguistics was too smart and you
wanted to play down
you wanted to sarah palin it you wanted
to go right red state with it because oh
jon hamm mr rapier mr big words you're
going to get the other half of the
audience well you lost them both i lost
everybody this thing's a disaster you
know what
i'm not going to do this picture with
you i'm going it alone can i give you
one idea if you if you if you're a dead
set on playing batman i'm open to your
hearing bring your son and his robin
is that a minute i mean i'm telling you
it's not a bad first of all physical
resemblance right second of all you
tower over him damn right i knew as a
child third of all he's clearly
comfortable playing second banana do you
he loves it there's three good reasons
you know what you are a smart sharp
fella
smart you're smart
what's the name of the movie friends
with kids what's the name of the tv show
mad men what is your name jon hamm i'm
jimmy pardo we'll see you next time on
the podcast
idiots that's not what we do
that's not a troll take it again
don't you will not
[Music]